[Applause]
oh
this is so interesting man bill gates
and melinda gates
have split up right now melinda comes
out
and says one of the reasons for the
split was because of what
i was rolling his eyes already well let
me just get it out one of the reasons
for the split
was because of haters
haters bro they'll be great though
he said one of she said one of the
reasons for the split was because
of bill's relationship with jeffrey
epstein okay
and she just couldn't tolerate it
tolerate it anymore she found out about
the meetings and then she started
trying to file for divorce i think back
in 2019 and i guess when the official
uh you know wall street journal new york
times article came out about their
relationship
and uh i mean this just proves what a
[ __ ]
just wretched [ __ ] hillary clinton is
dude when you think about it right
clinton hillary clinton has no feeling
in her heart
or [ __ ] the fact that she would still
be married
to bill clinton after he was besties
with jeffrey epstein
and melinda gates who knows likely her
husband's a scumbag
right like on at bare minimum just a
business scumbag
not even like a human being scumbag but
like willing to rip you off and being
like really tough in negotiations and
willing to like
crush companies that are going to try to
get in his way
basically not the most she was also like
a corporate exec to microsoft like she
might be also a scumbag
you know i mean like very he might be a
ruthless businesswoman very true she
married him when he was the richest man
in the world that's her business woman
but i feel like she's a corporate
executive microsoft in the same way like
memphis bleak is a corporate executive
do you know what i mean it was just like
all right i gotta give him a job
somewhere
you know what i mean like yeah this is
melinda bleak so i was like
she want to be on the foundation i be on
the foundation [ __ ] like
do whatever you got to do how do i get
to go away once a year with my
ex-girlfriend if you're on a foundation
you want to give away all your money so
i can't go away did you guys hear about
that part
you know yeah we're like wait wait which
part
but bill gates had a ex-girlfriend he
got to take one vacation a year with
yeah who's not not a piece decent feet
i looked at the feet decent feet decent
feet
decent feet back how awful is hillary
clinton bro
[Laughter]
but that's chicken's ugly son yeah but
her feet was we're fine bro
feet are decent feet yeah you're bill
gates you shouldn't be having to put up
with decent anything yeah you're true
but like bill gates don't believe he
deserves [ __ ] bro
he's a romantic that's what it is he's
romantic he loves this girl
he wants to talk about you know hedge
fund [ __ ] with her you know
i don't know back to uh i don't want to
bring hillary into it but it is shocking
that like
this [ __ ] does talk about believe all
women his [ __ ] don't believe in no
women bro
is there one woman that hillary clinton
believes about is there
the ones who voted for her just the ones
that voted for her i don't even know if
she believes those [ __ ] to be honest
with you yeah
it's unbelievable dude even women don't
like her
yo your husband was best friends with a
pedophile yeah you're not gonna question
that
a little bit you're not even gonna come
out and be like yo he should have used
better judgment
than to hang out on an island with the
pedophile yeah even if he didn't [ __ ] no
girls
just to go to the island a lot or hang
out with him yeah
there's no remorse whatsoever like even
trump came out he was like
i don't want to make this a [ __ ]
trump thing but wasn't didn't he come
out and be like
nah they were weird and there's some
weird shit's about to happen but
he likes them young or something like
that did he say something weird is gonna
happen to them like
yeah yeah he was like yeah epstein and
you know like some young and prince
andrew was hanging out with him and all
that [ __ ] yeah so even he was like yo
that's fat and then trump is a wild ass
boy
he also wished golly maxwell well so
like yeah i don't know sarcastic
i don't know yo free hers free hurts
yo get laid we were talking about that
on the train
the uh not the train in the airport
whatever that [ __ ] is
skytrain sky training yeah you really
just called the plane a train broke no
the train is like calling a car a vote
that's like
[Laughter]
but like we were talking about that like
yo is this how galen gets out
like if she feeds the feds bill is that
a big enough name
bill gates is that a big enough name
where we go okay elaine you can leave
you could go
scot-free bill i had this [ __ ] killed
no problem you think bro
no problem bill gonna have this [ __ ]
killed and [ __ ] victoria's secret guy
you can fear him vic bill had that got
killed too wexler whatever his name is
a wexner wexner we'll have everybody
killed you think though if you're not
bezos bill gates could get you
you think elon musk bill gates could get
you you two out here you think bill
gates could get him
yeah no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no guys might
be able to get you bro i'm not gonna
have some nerd kill me bro
he was chasing you at the [ __ ] wind
he probably was huh
he probably was but i was casing him too
i was casing him the whole time he got
strike first
yeah i knew it and i saw the way melinda
looked at me i was like oh this [ __ ]
out of here
she was throwing me some serious eye
contact yeah oh yeah
looking over it i'll check out toast she
was in some shitty ass little
tv sandals like i remember i told y'all
she was in tva sandals right
no i did i said she was in tv's she was
some khakis down here
she had the khakis down to here the way
i wear my body
yeah i think i was looking at me bro i
think i might have been looking at him
oh dude i caught again no i don't know
man this [ __ ] is wild what do you all
think about it
i think she's just trying to make a case
to justify how much money she's gonna
ask for
because the [ __ ] deserves nothing you
deserve nothing
you got the freest ride of free rides
you married the m
the richest man in the world for 27
years and now he got to pay you
you [ __ ] yo mckenzie was there from day
one
you hopped in you got the [ __ ] you
lived in a mansion for 27 years
your wildest fantasy fulfilled he [ __ ]
one other ugly girl once a year that's
all you get
and you think you're going to come for
some billions [ __ ] you greedy [ __ ]
how [ __ ] dare you leave disneyland
and then want to take the rides with you
how [ __ ] dare you you [ __ ]
i hate this [ __ ] so now to justify her
worth she's got to be like
oh he was a pedophile and i had a
problem no you didn't [ __ ]
that is true you did it didn't yeah now
all of a sudden it's a problem
you can't divorce a guy right away when
you find out he's a pedophile
two years it's got to take but it's also
like i hate this [ __ ]
how do you feel so much not to defend
her but like don't
wives always got a problem with like one
of your friends you know what i mean
like yes
you know like it is true like every wife
got a problem with one of her husband's
friends
you have to so maybe she was just like
all right that's
that's the guy i don't like you hanging
out with like i just would prefer if you
didn't hang out with him you always do
wild [ __ ] when you're with him
he brings out the worst in you yeah you
know yeah like being a pedophile like
being a pedophile like why were you
staying so late
it was passing girls bedtimes bro like
you should
they just found out he a pedophile you
married 27 years this just came up
also yeah that's convenience you've got
to be a little embarrassed if you bring
bill gates to like your island you know
what i mean like
because he's probably got multiple
islands like yeah but he don't got them
kids on his
it's the attractions it's not the island
yeah that's not the geography
yeah yeah yeah yeah but ireland's not
impressing bill gates like why else
would you go do bill gates go to the
island no i don't think so no i ain't
gonna go to the
medevac [ __ ] y'all yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i [ __ ] hate her you need to have
that
i hear what you say you wanted that same
energy from her before yo
yeah it's just she's gonna ask for a
ridiculous amount of money
is she gonna ask for more than mckenzie
bezos
i promise percentage-wise i don't know
about percentage-wise but i think gross
amount
yes that's that's what i think and she's
got to justify it somehow
so let me take the moral high ground of
oh i didn't like him hanging out with
epstein which is the easiest [ __ ]
moral high ground to take
even though you said nothing for years
once you say that he's starting the pr
machine now what'd she say as soon as it
came out they're getting divorced oh
here's why
but what i'm trying to say is like once
you hit him up like yo
i want this amount and he's like you're
wildin and then she's like nah you were
wildin with epstein remember
that even then 37 billion and it's too
much yeah the other reason why it seems
convenient
is that apparently she started filing
for divorce in 2019
after all the gates and stuff came out
so she knew about it but she knew
apparently she met with him
what what what is it from axe hold on
hold on hold on hold on from axios
apparently
uh the couple met epstein in 2013 to
discuss philanthropy
so apparently they both met with him in
2013 according to axios
is philanthropy a black teenage girl
they're trying to put her through school
bro that's foul
bro why would they do that to
philanthropy
bro and they met they're trying to help
charity too huh
they were trying to help charity also
that's his sister yeah philanthropy and
charity
up there oh that's crazy bro
yeah the gates were wild yeah yeah these
are some wild people sons of [ __ ]
both of them are sons of [ __ ] what do
you call a girl
[ __ ] daughter no there's no there's no
daughter of a [ __ ]
nah yeah cause that [ __ ] gets passed
down apples on far far from the tree you
know what i mean
i think i [ __ ] up the delivery but you
know what i'm trying to say though
this apple ass [ __ ] right next to that
bitch-ass tree
but you can't say daughter of a [ __ ]
nah daughter of a [ __ ] there's too many
stupid daughter of a [ __ ] you can't in
spanish say icha de puta
icho de puta ighadeputa son of a [ __ ]
beautiful when you said it daughter of a
[ __ ] in english it's a lot yeah it's a
mouthful what's another word for
daughter
[ __ ] we talking about melinda still
i hate this [ __ ] i hate this [ __ ] what
about bill do you hate him not wait i
mean i
don't ever want you to get divorced but
if you do that podcast
son if y'all get divorced on a sunday
let me tell you tuesday gonna be
wow that cannot happen i wish that never
happened
your reputation can't happen bro say
well for his reputation it can't happen
because he's gonna go wild
yo he's gonna go so [ __ ] well listen
i didn't say nothing about mckenzie
because mackenzie at least was there
from jump
this [ __ ] married the m the richest man
in the world and then she can act like
she's entitled to something
you did nothing this was a moving train
you caught a free ride
oh that's my issue and now you're going
to ask for money and now
take a moral hypothetically they began
dating in 1987.
come on son 19. [ __ ] out of here began
dating in nine days they did you made up
a year
according to cnn how do you have an
ex-girlfriend he started dating his
[ __ ] in 1987 because he was dating
no 80 year old [ __ ] taking her on an
island or whatever she's 70 lions
and melinda right now it's seen that
lion yes 70
bro can you just not believe that bill
gates has two girlfriends
that's what it is you're like look ready
her new gates name is this ann winblad
is the ex-girlfriend 70 years old 40
years of experience in software industry
okay yup she she uh she got a little
she looks a little bit like hey you guys
she got some hey you guys in her bro be
honest with you doc
she got some hey you guys but burged out
or not
she yeah johnson johnson she definitely
johnson johnson icebreaker
on my heart so ann and bill began dating
in 1984
meeting at computer conferences okay
they began going on virtual dates
calling each other on the phone
went to a number of trips together but a
couple of virgins central
africa dude the virtual dates in the 80s
is lit
stayed close after 1987 split gates had
an arrangement with his wife that he and
windblad can keep one vacation tradition
alive every spring
done for more than a decade they spent a
long weekend with winblade
and her beach cottage in north carolina
she was a cottage
oh [ __ ] let's go spring break and
gates out here dogs okay now let me just
ask you guys a question
this [ __ ] knew what he needed to
be the ideal husband
to to melinda he asked for it and he
delivered it
is that on bill or is that on melinda
everything is on melinda yo
everything's on melinda bill did nothing
wrong bill did nothing
wrong except maybe the xp and stuff i
don't have evidence of that yet the jury
is still out on that
but that's it i think the millen i think
melinda actually looks good in this that
she was like
that's cause you stupid bro dumb next
little boy
boy little boy
yeah like oh having fun like you need
this but like be honest with what you're
doing
oh yeah yeah yeah that was the least she
could have done one weekend a year
greedy ass [ __ ] you get 51 weekends
of the richest man in the world [ __ ]
are you out of your mind
you get 98 of his weekends hoe
come on yo he gets one a month
yeah you get 75 of bill but what if you
don't want to hang out with hey you guys
once a month then he gets he got other
other girls that's once a year
that's not how bill is bro bill would be
into hey you guys
he won't hang out all the goonies
probably
i think she actually looks good i really
do that's the only place where she looks
good ever including her face
not melinda's all right i don't know
what she looks like you are a hater
i have no idea what she looks like quite
frankly never looked at a picture of her
because why would i
hear
what am i missing wait what look look at
hey you guys what am i missing
that's his mystery eyepiece my sidekick
should be hotter well he gotta get an
ugly enough side piece where his main
piece could be like all right [ __ ] that
ugly [ __ ] yep uh-huh
well you can't [ __ ] a battery this guy
knows how to run a monopoly bro that's
the whole thing with the monopolies you
can't make it to monopolistic you got to
have some little competition on the side
so it doesn't look like a monopoly so
you can keep running your [ __ ]
that's what he's doing this guy
understands anti-trust bro he broke the
trust because his anti-trust he knows it
he knows it bro
that was some word play right here yeah
it doesn't actually make sense if you
think about it
that goes with you somebody's auntie old
ass [ __ ] i'll tell you that much right
now all right
so um in conclusion
has been reached we know how you feel
about this why do you feel different
about mckenzie
mckenzie was there from the jump and she
was there from 87. and she's giving all
her money away you don't know what
melinda's doing she's a foundation
oh is she with charity hold on she has a
foundation let me ask you this question
don't worry about foundation
what what when did microsoft start
let's find out if that should have
started in 1988
he would be my greatest man in the world
when they got married no that's not true
yeah no that's not true you don't know
that well it's more fun if it's not true
until we find out
okay all right i'm just trying to keep i
don't believe 1987.
so i don't know what [ __ ] 4chan
website he's reading that off of 1975
they got married
1975 no no no 1975 microsoft was founded
yeah oh
so this is 12 years later yeah yeah bruh
oh no dude come on get in there all
right
get in there let her
so he became the richest man in 1995.
and when did they get married they they
started dating in 1980 when did they get
married
they got married in 1994. oh that's a
lie
alex no that's true
see mm-hmm he was only the second
richest man in the world when they got
married
start moonwalking well i gotta move on
to
second place
you marrying elon musk that's pretty
[ __ ] good uh he number two
they were dating in 1987. that's a lie
dog that's some [ __ ] she said to make
herself look good
what woman you know date [ __ ] 12
years before you get married
this girl is confident she's out here
she's like yes he's been had microsoft
1987. bro in 1987 he was only worth 1.2
billion
nothing nothing [ __ ] pockets bro
that's pockets bro
that's dust bunnies that's pockets no
this [ __ ] married a billionaire started
dating a billionaire got lucky enough to
marry him and then gonna act like
she got some [ __ ] moral high ground
to get money you get
you get 400 000 i'm being generous
that is interesting like what should a
wife get
wait do they have kids yeah they've got
four kids
actually like i don't know what one of
them what i don't know how old they are
well let's look at the ages let's look
at the ages because you know mark be on
the internet
[Laughter]
he got a female female kid bro whoa
oh
yo look at that little bow legged red
bone [ __ ] right there so hold on how
old is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh
okay hold on give me the ages out bust
down these ages bro
you find the agent mark tell us the
goddamn age get in the table
i'm trying to wait times so maybe it'll
go you know
18 21 25. let's
[ __ ] go hold on which one is which
and bring them out again
i need to see instagram accounts i need
to see instagram accounts be assured
with the red hair was looking kind of
cute
oh boy oh
boy i think we stumbled upon a gold mine
in 1987 when she met bill but still you
gonna [ __ ] it up for all of us cause
you're hating on their mom so much
yeah dude come on bro that's gonna be
this could be an in-law of one of us
bill gates produced some nice little
[ __ ] when you think about it
i'm leaving
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you